It was dark when two mysterious,
shrouded figures
appeared in the hillside village.
The strangers knocked on every door
in town, asking for food and shelter.
But, again and again,
they were turned away.
Soon, there was just one door left:
that of a small, thatched shack.
An elderly couple, Baucis and Philemon,
answered the thunderous knock.
Although there was something
off about these visitors,
it was in the pair’s nature
to care for those in need.
Philemon invited them to rest,
and the cottage flooded with warmth
as Baucis teased the fire back to life.
When they were young, Baucis and Philemon
had fallen in love,
married,
and settled in the humble cottage.
Decades later, their home
was still standing—
and they were more devoted
to each other than ever.
The strangers watched intently as Baucis
nestled twigs under a battered pot
filled with vegetables.
The couple could rarely afford meat,
but in honor of their guests,
Philemon cut strips from an aging shank
for the stew.
They made cheerful conversation
and offered their visitors hot baths.
Baucis used a chip of broken clay
to balance the wobbly table’s legs
and rubbed its surface with mint
until it smelled sweet and fresh.
Weaving around each other with care,
the couple transformed
what they had into a feast.
Soon, the tabletop overflowed with food
and the last of their sweet wine.
Privately, Baucis and Philemon worried
that their provisions would run out.
Yet, as the night wore on,
and their strange guests
took hearty gulps of wine,
the clay vessel never ran dry.
The couple, at first relieved,
grew terrified.
Their guests weren’t humble peasants
traveling the countryside.
They were almost certainly gods
in disguise—
but which gods,
they didn’t know.
Panicked that their preparations
were inadequate,
Baucis and Philemon searched
for another offering.
The only precious thing left was
the goose that guarded their home.
The couple repeatedly lunged
after the bird,
but they were too worn out for the chase.
So, they prepared to receive
the wrath of the gods.
Their guests rose up,
shedding their rags and mortal masks.
Looming before them was Zeus,
the storm-brewing ruler of the gods,
and his son, Hermes,
the fleet-footed messenger
who shepherded mortals to the underworld.
The gods told the old couple that,
unlike the other townspeople,
they had shown true xenia,
or loving hospitality to strangers.
They alone had passed the test.
The gods commanded the couple
to follow them,
and the group ascended
the nearest mountain.
Nearing the summit,
Baucis and Philemon looked back—
but were shocked to see a murky swamp
where their village stood
just moments before.
As punishment for refusing
to shelter the gods,
Zeus and Hermes had cast
the townspeople underwater,
leaving only their hosts’ home intact,
Recalling their friends and neighbors,
Baucis and Philemon couldn’t hide
their terror and mournful tears,
even as their house transformed below.
It grew larger and sprouted
marble pillars and steps.
Legends etched themselves
onto its grand doors.
Their rickety cottage had metamorphosed
into a gleaming temple for the gods.
Hermes commended the couple and gently
asked if there was anything they desired.
After a brief discussion, Philemon
requested that he and Baucis
be permitted to care for the new temple.
And he asked if, when their time came,
they could die together,
so neither would have to face life
without the other.
Tending to the temple and one another,
they lived many more years.
Until, one day, Baucis noticed leaves
fluttering from her husband’s hands
and looked down to find
her own skin hardening.
They embraced, becoming rooted in place.
Vines wound around their legs
and canopies flourished overhead.
They bid each other a loving,
last farewell as humans.
And where Baucis and Philemon
had just stood, bent with age,
there towered a linden and an oak tree,
their branches intertwined for eternity.